the greek myth of a serpent-like
creature known as hydra
helped inspire one of the most nefarious
organizations in the marvel universe
clearly there's a lot of history behind
this sinister neo-fascist group but if
you're feeling confused
don't worry this is the history of
marvel's hydra
explained although many believe that
hydra originated during world war
ii its tentacles actually stretched back
much farther
in the marvel universe before the dawn
of humanity a group of immortal reptoids
arrived on earth with the intention of
spreading their evil across the land
millions of years later these same
creatures would corrupt an eastern
secret society called the brotherhood of
the spear
who worshipped the reptoids as the beast
the brotherhood spread throughout the
rest of the world and integrated
themselves into
all aspects of human civilization as
time went on the society changed its
name to hydra
compromising the cathary sect of
christianity in the thule society
the latter of which evolved into the
nazi party the hydra timeline at the end
of 2009 secret warriors 1
revealed that all mentions of this
ancient organization are absent in
history books after the renaissance
which may explain how they stayed hidden
for so long
hydra was never actually part of the
nazi party in the marvel universe but
would still go on to become a neo-nazi
organization
wolfgang von strucker was a close
confidant of adolf hitler who fought a
losing battle against the allies and
their forces which included captain
america and the invaders
hitler grew tired of strucker's constant
defeat and sentenced him to death
strucker escaped to japan with the help
of hitler's second in command johann
smith aka red skull who foresaw that the
nazis would lose world war ii
while in japan strucka discovered a
secret organization created but no
longer led by red skull
made up of fugitives from nazi germany
and imperial japan
after killing the organization's leader
strzok renamed the group hydra
and restructured it with an eye toward
global domination
cementing it as a neo-nazi terrorist
organization
in the comics strucker found a way to
infiltrate the international
peacekeeping organization shield
shortly after its formation thomas
davidson an early programmer at shield
defected to hydra and created an entire
system for strucker that gave him
unrestricted access to shield
strucka then killed davidson so no one
else could have control of this system
or so he thought as nick fury later
revealed to strzok the davidson he
killed was
actually a life model decoy the real
davidson lived on
turning the tables against hydra without
their knowledge as nick fury put it to
strzok
we were watching you watching us hydra's
secret remained hidden from the world
until a month before the events of
secret warriors one
nick fury who'd lost his leadership
position at shield
broke into a shield datacore facility in
chicago called the carousel
fury accessed everything there was to
know about the organization
and blew up the carousel in order to
cover his tracks but not before making a
personal copy of all his findings
no one outside of hydra knew what he
knew until the end of secret warriors
won
when fury told fellow agent daisy
johnson aka quake that hydra had been
hiding inside shield for decades
shield's been compromised you said so
yourself hydra grew right under your
nose and nobody noticed
following the events of the secret
invasion storyline
nick fury established the secret
warriors as a team of relatively unknown
superheroes to fight against the skrull
invasion
after the team discovered that hydra was
hiding inside shields however they found
a new purpose
to take down hydra and shield along with
it
conversely strucker convened the high
council of hydra
after he learned that fury had
discovered the truth about shield
the council included viper kraken madame
hydra
hive and a newly resurrected gorgon
various battles ensued between the
secret warriors and hydra
up until secret warriors 25 when kraken
kidnapped fury and struck her
the following issue revealed that kraken
was fury's brother jake who was working
as a double agent
and that fury made struck a think he was
controlling shield when he was actually
working for fury the whole time
after fury executed strucker and secret
warriors 27
gorgon and viper allied with norman
osborne and his hammer organization in
new avengers 16.1
and 17 but they were all defeated viper
then used the remaining hammer troops to
reinforce hydra and avengers 24
but that failed too strucka was a
dominant force in the marvel universe
starting with his first appearance in
1964's
sergeant fury and his howling commandos
5. but the supreme hydra would
eventually meet his demise in 1967
strange tales 158
in that comic fury confronted strucker
on his personal base of operations
hydra island during one of their
encounters fury used hydra's epiderm
mask machine to change struck his face
into furies
the real fury then made two different
struck a mask
when hydra guard saw two struckers
fighting they unmasked one of them to
reveal fury when in actuality
it was struck her wearing a fury mask
nevertheless
struck a panic and indiscriminately
jumped into an alpha particle reactor
cube where he was incinerated
meanwhile the disguised fury escaped
hydra island and detonated strucker's
death spore bio weapon
inside the domed island according to the
data core and fury files in secret
warriors 1
strucker's influence still loomed large
as his supposed death
caused hydra to split into three
factions the leading hydra council of
them
the terrorist organization known as aim
and the hydra subsidiary secret empire
after strucker was resurrected in nick
fury agent of shield 21
he started killing off leaders of
several splinter groups
in order to unite them under a new hydra
regime
unfortunately for strzok this
reorganization did not stop a civil war
from erupting hitting him
against the combined allied forces of
his wife ellsbeth
and her lover gorgon while baron helmut
zemo
placed strucka and stasis for his own
nefarious purposes
gorgon and elsbeth hatched a plot to
seize control of hydra
in wolverine 22 they created a clone of
strucka for a ritual sacrifice that
occurred three issues later
thankfully the formerly brainwashed
wolverine killed the two
and stopped them from carrying out their
evil plans flash forward to 2006
in new thunderbolt 17 where the real
strucka awoken from stasis
teamed up with zemo to take over the
world much to the dismay of his son
andreas von strucker
aka swordsman issues 519 through 524 of
the amazing spider-man
revealed that pharmaceutical
manufacturer edgar lascombe replaced
gorgon as the new supreme hydra while
strzok was still in stasis
last comb believed that hydra had become
weak under his current leadership
devolving into yet another crime
syndicate focused on drug running and
money laundering
as such he had the leaders killed and
seized control of the organization
lascombe used a group of genetically
altered hydra agents called the hydra
iv whose powers and abilities were all
based around captain america
thor iron man and hawkeye to distract
the new avengers while hydra smuggled
missiles and bacteria into new york
this was part of a larger plan to launch
a bio-weapon attack on the ogallala
aquifer and bring america to its knees
fortunately
spider-man figured out this plan and
with the help of the new avengers
stopped last comb but not before he and
the hydra 4
escaped their now defunct secret base as
of this video
neither last comb nor the hydra 4 has
appeared in another marvel comic
in the midst of the marvel's avengers
standoff comic event from 2016
the sentient cosmic cube child known as
kobik decided to look for red skull
in captain america steve rogers 2 red
skull manipulated kobik into creating an
alternate timeline where steve rogers
was a hydra agent replacing the real
steve with his fascist iteration
after red skull turned his greatest
enemy into a valuable asset
he created a new hydra from the ground
up with the help of various neo-nazi and
white supremacist groups
red skull returned hydra to its nazi
roots this neo-hydra recruited political
extremists
used guerrilla tactics and carried out
terrorist attacks against civilians in
america
and western europe neohydra is very
evocative of the real-life
alt-right movement which was in the news
when this comic was released
unfortunately for red skull his reign as
hydra's leader came to an end in captain
america's steve rogers 15.
in the controversial secret empire event
captain america became hydra supreme
exiling several heroes and taking over
the united states
many americans became used to this
fascist regime mainly because hydra put
mind-altering substances in water
supplies to increase obedience
the new regime also displaced all
mutants to a sovereign region
called new teon and deported all
inhumans to detention centers
a superhero resistance group called the
underground hatched a plan to bring back
the original captain america and stop
hydra supreme in the final issue of
secret empire
sam wilson aka the new captain america
surrendered his fragment of the cosmic
cube to hydra supreme
what hydra supreme didn't realize
however was that ant-man shrunk bucky
barnes so he could travel into the cube
and pull out kobik and the real captain
america both captain america and hydra
supreme
fought until the latter tried to lift
thor's hammer and failed which prompted
captain america to break hydra supreme's
armor with the hammer
and defeat him once and for all although
the scars of this event never healed the
united states returned to normal in the
following weeks
the winter soldier revelation that hydra
infiltrated shield also had major
effects on the abc series agents of
shield
captain america the first avenger
introduced hydra as the nazi science
division but agents of shield season 3
revealed that hydra started out as a
fanatical cult that worshipped the
ancient inhuman known as hive
a member of that cult wilfred malek
remained connected to the world war ii
era hydra and in the season seven
episode know your onions he gave them a
key ingredient of the super soldier
serum which johan schmidt later used to
turn himself into red skull
season 5 sees u.s air force general hale
as the last known high-ranking leader of
hydra in the mcu
hale tries to form a deal with an
intergalactic alliancee called the
confederacy to protect them from thanos
but they ultimately side with the
gravitonium-infused glenn talbot
who later kills hale hydra has not
reappeared in the mcu
since except for in avengers in-game
when the avengers travel back in time
hey elendra mcu fans last saw
arnhem zola as a complex computer system
in captain america the winter soldier
but he actually has a much bigger role
in the comics
dr arnhem zola who first appeared in
captain america 208 was a swiss
scientist who worked for the nazis
during world war
ii he became the lead scientist of
project nietzsche where he created super
soldiers to serve the nazi's quest for
world domination
at some point zola created a robot body
for himself
to replace his frail human body and
survive into modern times
this robotic figure allowed bipedal
movement and projected an
image of zola's face on a screen located
on its chest
if one of these robots were destroyed
zola could simply transfer himself into
another
in short zola is one of captain
america's more durable villains
baron helmut zemo is one of the most
memorable villains in the marvel
universe
helmut is the son of nazi scientist
heinrich zemo who launched the plane
that froze captain america in ice for
decades
after heinrich died in a rock slide
during a fight with the centennial of
liberty
helmut wanted to avenge his father's
death and became the supervillain known
as the phoenix
in captain america 168 zemo captured cap
and held him over a vat of adhesive x
unfortunately for helmut his plan
backfired and he fell into the vat
instead
although he was thought to be dead
helmut returned in 1982's captain
america 275
helmet has appeared frequently
throughout marvel comics as baron zemo
and at one point he was the leader of
hydra actor daniel bruhl portrayed zemo
in captain america civil war
and reprises his role in the disney plus
miniseries the falcon and the winter
soldier
hydra henchmen wear green jumpsuits that
make them indistinguishable from one
another
but one henchman has risen above the
rest and his name
is bob bob first appeared in 2007's
cable in deadpool 38 and he only joined
hydra
because his wife nagged him to find a
steady job in that issue
deadpool infiltrated a hydra base in
pakistan along with weasel to save their
friend agent x
he coerced bob into helping him and told
bob to steal a jet to fly them out
since his introduction bob has been
featured regularly as deadpool's
sidekick although he shows extreme
cowardice
he's saved deadpool on several occasions
rob hader cameoed as bob in the deadpool
film
appearing as one of ajax's henchmen who
deadpool spared during
the movie's climax bob
wait oh my god i haven't seen you since
jacksonville dgi friday
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
marvel comics movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one